Herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO DPU. Herzlich willkommen. Dü, dü, dü, dü. Eins, eins, null. Es brennt. Ja, nee. Eins, eins, zwei, die Feuerwehrfolge. Oh, wo brennt's denn? Gibt es einen Gag-Alarm? Haben Sie Gags verschüttet auf der Autobahn? Oh ja, das gibt es noch richtig. Der Giftnotruf, 1, 2, 8, den kriegen wir auch noch dran, Freunde.
Gag-Vergiftung. Oh! Doktor Tietz und Doktor Wilber in den Gag-OP. Es gibt so viele giftige Beeren, ne? Wir haben letztens in so einem kleinen Außenort gedreht und da gab es so eine ganze Hecke mit drei verschiedenen Beeren, die man alle nicht essen konnte, wo ich mir denke... Obwohl du erst am ersten standest, jemand musst du rufen, nicht angehen, giftig!
Ja.
Und dann zwei Sekunden später, Florian, auch da weggehen bitte, ist giftig!
Generelle Regel, generelle Regel! Drehregel, Florentin geht nicht an Beeren, die nicht in Schüsseln angerichtet stehen. Wo ich mir auch denke, wie fucking arrogant sind Leute, die einen Garten haben, die sagen, nö, ich pflanze hier schon giftige Beeren an die Grenze zwischen mir und der Eussen-Außenwelt, so dass kleine Kinder, die vorbeistrieben, natürlich als Elternteil muss man den Kindern natürlich beibringen, hier pass auf, alles giftig, aber man kann auch einfach sagen, nee, pass auf, wir können auch einfach schlicht keine giftigen Pflanzen mehr pflanzen, verrückte Idee, und Kinder gehen eh nicht mehr in den Wald, weil die bei Candy Clash die ganze Zeit am Bildschirm hängen und sich neue Herzen runterladen für viel gelte Eltern. Gesellschaftskritik. Naja, ich würde sagen, es ist auch ein bisschen, die Natur ist aber auch gemein, weil die giftigen Pflanzen sind der Fingerhut, das klingt schon so süss, man will sich auf den Finger stecken, wenn man isst, stirbt man. Maiglöckchen, die kleinen süsten Maiglöckchen, man will sie mal in den Mund nehmen, wenn du isst, stirbst du. Die müssten Terrorseuche heißen oder sowas und nicht Maiglöckchen. Wer hat die Maiglöckchen? Irgend so ein Sadist hat die Maiglöckchen genannt. Dann hier Eiben, diese kleinen süssen roten Beeren, wenn du die isst, stirbst du. Ist aber oft so, dass... Tollkirschen, sieht aus wie Kirschen, wenn du die isst, stirbst du. Die heißen sogar Tollkirsche, Tolle Kirsche. Sie sollten Schlechtkirschen heißen. Okay, Tollkirsche soll ich nicht essen, Sauerkirsche völlig in Ordnung. Tollwut, I'm getting mixed signals, I'm getting mixed, es ist toll oder es ist Wut. Es ist aber oft so, dass schreckliche Dinge gute Namen haben, zum Beispiel im Ersten Weltkrieg eingesetzt, Senfgas, ganz schreckliches Gas, wenn man die Lunge aussieht. SS klingt. SS, yum, yum, das klingt alles gut. War bestimmt irgendwie so eine nordkoreanische Folter-Einheit namens Njam Njam. Wie heißen sie? Wir sind die Njam Njam. Okay, klingt gut. So kann man auch fein, weil diese ganzen Flieger, das war ja auch bei Dunkirk so, diese Flieger, die dann diese Streubomben streuen, keine Ahnung, diese Flieger, die so in Sturzflug kommen aus großer Höhe und dann diese Bomben verstreuen, die haben doch auch so Namen und so, die heißen dann irgendwie, auch die Panzer heißen ja Leoparden und so und du kannst Feinde auch Mürbe machen, wenn du deine Flieger dann irgendwie so Teddybären nennst oder so. Nein, Leute, die fucking Teddybären! Der kommt! Ja, vor allem, ich meine, es gibt natürlich den Leopard und den Tiger, aber dann gibt es halt auch Maus und Wiesel, glaube ich, gibt es auch so kleine Truppentransporter, wo du einfach denkst, ja, ich bin der Mäuschen, Leutnant Weidenburg, ich bin Oberkommandeur von der Maus. Das ist wirklich cool. Ja, mein Name ist Klaus von Dönitz, ich leite hier die ganze Maikäferarmee, alle Maikäfer gehorchen mir. Aber es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass das glaube ich, ich glaube nur bei der Bundeswehr oder international, die Farbe der Panzer ist pink, ist rosa und ihr habt mal so ein Interview gesehen, wenn so ein Panzerkommandeur da saß und der r der Rosa irgendwie kann er, Infrantie ist blau, Artillerie ist
gelb mit blauen Punkten
und irgendwie Kavallerie hat so rote Sternchen.
Man muss die auch auseinanderhalten
können, der sagt so, was, ein
riesiger Metallkoloss, was bist du
denn? Ach, Rosa, okay,
gar nicht. Und dann hat dieser Panzerkommandeur
dann so erzählt, ja, unsere
traditionelle Farbe ist ja Rosa und Bundeswehr ist ja so ein Männerverein, da kann es halt mit rosa nicht ankommen. Dann sagen die, ja, das kommt davon, dass früher die Panzereinheiten kommen von den Kavallerieeinheiten und früher, da haben die so über ihren Satteln so rote Tücher getragen, die Elite-Kavallerie. Also rot, also warum haben sie nicht einfach rot? Lass mich bitte kurz ausreden. Sorry. Und dann über die Zeit, weil die halt viel gekämpft haben, die Elite-Kavallerie, hat sie sich so abgenutzt und dann wurde dieses Rot, dieses Hermelin-Rot, dieses Edle-Rot, wurde halt zu einem Rosa. Also sind sie ja sowas wie abgenutzt. Sie sind so eine abgenutzte Truppe. Ich würde sagen, Kampf erprobt. Kampf erprobt und davon hat sich halt das Rosa oder also Pink abgeleitet für unsere Leopard-Vier-Panzer-Todeslaser-Tornado-Einheiten. Warum haben Sie jetzt auch noch eine pinke Mütze auf? Ich reiche das nicht. Wie gesagt, im Gefecht haben wir Helme auf, momentan ist es klar. Warum muss der Panzer pink sein? Früher war mal das Tarnfarbe, jetzt ist alles pink. Auch das leitet sich ab von den Husaren, die eine sehr erfolgreiche Kabinett hat. Die mit den neongelben Panzern ankommen. Die weissen Plüschhandschellen müssen wir, das ist das Vertraglich Gewerkschaftliche, das das geleitet. Und diese kleinen Pistolechen, wo vorne so dieses Peng rauskommt. Ich glaube, wir kommen hier nicht weiter. Ich glaube, wir machen eine gute Arbeit da unten im Libanon oder wo immer. Im Nimmerland, meinen Sie, da machen Sie gute Arbeit. Okay, wir brechen hier ab, es
wird nichts. Einfach, kann man einfach nicht ernst.
Ich kann Krieg auch nie ernst nehmen, ich weiß nicht.
Ich hoffe ja so ein bisschen, jetzt ist ja auch,
ich lese dann immer die Zeit,
Eilmeldungen, komplett auf mein Handy und jetzt
will Donald Trump, will
Nordkorea ausmerzeln, ganz komplett,
ist das Wort ausmerzeln? Merkel.
Merkel.
Und jetzt hoffe ich auch so ein bisschen, dass da ein bisschen... Da ist mir gerade eine Satire passiert. Tut mir leid. Es rutet einem manchmal so raus, man kann sich abschalten. Ich habe gerade satiert. Jetzt muss ich das alles weglesen. Jetzt habe ich hier alles hinsattet. Sorry, alles voll satiert. Können Sie wieder aufhören, jetzt so hinzusattet? Entschuldigung. Ich hoffe jedenfalls, dass da mal was passiert. Einfach mal ordentlich so, damit ich wieder Angst vor Krieg. Ich glaube, wir brauchen immer wieder alle Angst vor Krieg. Wir würden uns immer lustig machen über diese kleinen... Das stimmt. Krieg denkt sich auch so, Mars, der Kriegsgott, denkt sich, ja, aber ihr wisst schon, da fließt Blut und das ist schrecklich und die armen Witwen. Und immer mit euren Rovern, immer mit einem scheiß Mars, die Drohnen fliegen über das Gesicht, komm, Leute, es gibt auch Kämpfende Menschen. Einfach schrecklich. Ja, die großen Kriege sind vorbei. Glaubst du, dass irgendwann, weil diese Drohnen werden ja so ferngesteuert, also stelle ich mir das vor, dass jemand steht mit so einem Controller, PS1-Controller an so einer großen Antenne, und da stehen er da unten, aber es sind immer unkülle Leute. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du die Leute kennst, ich habe auch damals mal ferngesteuert so ein Flugzeug gehabt, und da bist du halt immer bei, also du bist als Kind nicht gut aufgehoben in dieser Gesellschaft von alten, dicken Männern mit so karierten Shirts, auf denen sie ganz groß, pädophil, einfach so pädophil draufstehen, so ein großes Schild, und dann stehen die da mit ihren riesen, lächerlich grossen Fernbedienungen, so grossen Kopfhörern, alle Erektionen, alle, eine lange Erektion, zwei Meter lang. Und dann stehen die da halt mit ihren riesen, diese lächerlich großen Modellflugzeugen und dann sausen die halt durch und können das auch gut, die könnten das interessant und cool gestalten mit Loopings und so, nee, die wollen halt dann genauso fliegen wie normale Flieger fliegen. Wow, geil. Und dann, das sind doch Leute, die dann auch im Ernstfall wahrscheinlich so diese Drohnen kriegen, diese furchtbaren, bring the pedophiles in, wir brauchen die Elite-Pädophilien. Genozid-ähnlichen Massenvernichtungskriege einfach mit diesen Drohnen, dies werden die sein, die die führen. So Leute mit so gelangweilt so einer Brille, die dann vor so einem grossen Controller stehen. Auf jeden Fall denen auch immer so den Knüppel desinfizieren, bevor sie anfangen und dann so alles muss genau reinlich sein. Aber auch so, also noch schlimmer,
also wirklich, ich finde, das ist ja schon extrem
langweilig, also Modellflugzeug bauen
und so, alles cool, kann ich mir vorstellen. Aber dann ist
fliegen lassen, es gibt kein Ziel,
es gibt keine Herausforderung, es ist einfach nur so
okay, können wir wieder heimgehen,
jetzt instant, tschüss. Aber noch
schlimmer, als ich das erste Mal
der größte Feind der Wind
und andere Eltern schmeißt dir immer aufmerksame Eltern, das erste Mal camp war. Der größte Feind der Wind. Der Wind und andere Eltern.
Der schmeißt dir immer
aufmerksame Eltern. Das ist auch gefährlich.
Aber die können dir immer ein Kreuz durch die Rechnung machen.
Und so kleine Kinder, die versuchen,
mit Bögen abzuschießen, die Flugzeuge, was wir
früher gemacht haben, unsere Drachen. Aber was ja noch
langweiliger ist, sind ja ferngesteuerte Schiffe,
Boote. Einfach so, wir haben gekämmt
an einem See und dann kommen die da
und wirklich
und du denkst dir wirklich instant innerhalb von 0,30 Minuten, okay, hab gar keinen Bock mehr.
Einfach so sofort, das Fliegel fährt einmal raus, scharfe Kurve wieder zurück und zurück ins Auto.
Ja, vor allem gehört auch, also erstmal, die können ja nicht so schnell sein, weil die Motoren sind ja auch so klein und so und dann sind die auch so, also Fliegen ist zumindest was Tolles so, aber die meisten, viele Dinge schwimmen, die kannst du einfach reinlegen, dann schwimmen die schon so, also Holz, du kannst einfach so einen Holzblock reinschmeißen, das schwimmt dann schon irgendwie, aber diese Kunst zu fliegen kann ich schon irgendwie nachvollziehen, dann schwebst du was durch die Luft, das ist cool, aber. Tatsächlich in dem selben Urlaub, wir fahren ja da schon seit Jahrzehnten hin und ganz früher, als wir noch kleine Knaben waren und Interesse an Technik und wie ist die Welt aufgebaut und wir brauchen uns ein Luftgewehr und wir bauen uns ein Katapult, da hatten wir tatsächlich irgendwann mal die Idee, dass wir einen Wettbewerb machen, wer kann das beste Boot bauen, aber zu klein und welches dann halt so irgendwie so groß wie halt ein Baguette oder sowas. Vielleicht du wirst nie raten, worauf ich mein Boot gebaut habe. Lass mich dir mal an einen Croissant. Und dann war die Aufgabe, jeder sollte ein Boot und dann sollten wir gucken, welches am längsten schwimmt. Dann tun wir es in den See und gucken dann, welches am längsten schwimmt und wir alle schnitzen und bauen. Und MS Baguette ist direkt untergegangen. Knusprig nochmal irgendwie über dem Feuer rösten und so. Und alle kommen mit ihren Booten mit Fähnchen und toll dekoriert ans Wasser, lassen es hin. Und einer unserer Freunde, der Pragmatiker, hat einfach eine leere Plastikflasche, schraubt den Deckel zu und wirft sie ans Wasser. Einfach so, ja, see you later, losers! Einfach so. Und wir alle so, oh. Er hat gewonnen, natürlich. Natürlich hat er gewonnen, ja. Ich war ein riesen Sandburg-Fan. Ich war immer an der Ostsee, in der Lübecker Bucht Urlaub machen, und dann gab es da irgendwann mal Sandworld. Hast du jemals ein Sandworld miterlebt? Nee. Dann waren so Künstler, kamen dann an diesen Ort, irgendwo in Travemünde war das, und haben halt crazy Sandburgen gebaut und dann so riesen Prominente nachgebaut und so. Und dann konnte man halt da so ein Werkzeug kaufen, um das auch selber zu machen. Und dann habe ich mit meinen ganzen Freunden da im Urlaub, haben uns halt dieses Werkzeug gekauft und haben dann am Strand versucht, das Städte nachzubauen. Und es wurde so crazy gut irgendwann, weil das Einzige, was du brauchst, es ist nicht Skill, es ist nicht irgendwie künstlerisches Talent, du brauchst nur dieses Werkzeug. Einfach, du musst irgendwie, dass du Sand gut gerade machen kannst oder so, mit so Spachteln und so weiter. Und das haben wir halt alle gemacht und dann irgendwann haben Leute anderem Fotos gemacht, weil das so cool aussah, weil wir so Krokodile gebaut haben. Das war richtig geil. Und die Erwachsenen denken sich, okay, die machen das jetzt zehn Minuten, sind besser als wir. Fuck. Und welche Prominenten haben die so nachgebaut? Sandy Warhol? Oh mein Gott! Aber auch so wie, kann man auch so einfach denken, ist es so offensichtlich, man bleibt in irgendwas Kindlichem hängen einfach. Ah, jetzt denk nach, gut, denk nach, von mir aus.
Sandra Bullock. Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Sand ohne Namen. Sandro Garfield.
Sandro Lloyd Webber.
Sandy Owen. Arnold Sandsenegger, Bradley Cooper, Matthew McConaughey, Sand. Alle halt, einfach dem alle nachgebaut. Okay, ich verstehe. Und du verstehst das System. Und die haben wirklich einfach krass so einen Eiffelturm nachgebaut. Und dann hatten die auch so einen speziellen Sand tatsächlich, der sehr, wurde mir damals erklärt, sehr viereckig ist. Also der hat, wenn man mikroskopisch guckt, dann sind es nicht so kleine abgerundete Sandkörner, sondern so kleine eckige, und die verkanten sich dann so einander. Heißt, du kannst so Brücken bauen, ohne dass sie zusammenbrechen. Was ich mir so unfair fand, weil wir mit diesem herkömmlichen scheiß Ostsee-Billigsand da unterwegs waren. Hat auch funktioniert. So dieser Saharasand, dieses Pulver eigentlich fast, ne? Ja, ja, Pulver. Das ganze Sahara. Reizt sich das Wüste? Mal in die Wüste? Nee, mich reizt, ich habe auch neulich eine Doku beim Buddhismus angeguckt. Ich glaube, ich wäre Buddhist. Ja? Ja. Aber was hatte ich gehuckt? Was hatte ich? Ich habe mir die ersten fünf Minuten geguckt, dann bin ich eingeschlafen. Dieses ganze Meditationsding. Nirvana? Moment, ganz kurz. Das ist Buddhismus? Nirvana, ja. Wenn du die Erleuchtung hast, dann kommst du ... Erst wirst du immer wiedergeboren und immer wieder. Dann hast du die Erleuchtung und dann kommst du ins Nirvana. Genau, soweit ich es verstanden habe, du strebst nach der Erleuchtung und meditierst und versuchst dein Ego und so alles gedöhnt. Aber wenn du dann erleuchtet bist, dann hast du die Wahl, entweder du gehst ins Nirvana und bist dann so eine Art Gott-Engels-Wesen oder du kehrst wieder zurück auf die Erde und wirst dann Bodhisattva und lehrst dann den anderen Leuten, wie man selber erleuchtet werden kann.
Kann aber auch Hinduismus sein.
Und das bist du.
Genau.
Nee, nee, nee, hier.
Nee, das stimmt schon, glaube ich.
Egal.
Aber sowas ist ja egal.
Weil mir ist auch gefallen,
manche Religionen machen es nämlich gut,
die haben nämlich so, also so,
also Christentum hat es gut gemacht schon.
Die haben halt das Kreuz,
Jesus, nur mal das catchy.
Alle haben es verstanden.
Ja, Buddhismus Hakenkreuz.
Good job, guys. Das einzige fucking Zeichen. PR-Desaster. Buddhismus hat diesen fetten Typen, Buddha. Und einfach diese ganze Meditationsnummer. Cool, kaufe ich. Judentum, weiß ich nicht genau, was da anders ist, haben auch Jesus und Alte Testament und so ein Bullshit. Diese Höfen. Dann der Islam, macht es auch clever. Mit diesen Muezzin, die durch die ganze Stadt brüllen, auf diesen großen Türmen und diese Richtung Mekka-Gedöns, der große Würfel, den die anbeten, der immer auf der welchen Seite liegt. Wenn sich das jemand ausdenken würde, wenn jetzt mal so Freunde, pass auf, ich hab hier eine Serie über eine Religion, die einen großen Würfel hat, und dann gibt's eine mit Kreuz, die bauen ganz hohe Tür mit Glocken drin. Verrückt. Ja, aber das ist alles, die haben alle so ihr Catch-Ding, aber Hinduismus? Sorry. Hallo, der Punkt auf der Stirn, wie cool ist das denn? Ne, aber das weiß niemand, was das bedeutet. Klar, drittes Auge, damit sieht man Drittes Auge? Ja, das ist drittes Auge. Warum meinen die kein Auge? Das ist aufwendig, du musst das ja jeden Tag abschminken, glaube ich, oder? Das ist der Aufwand, weil das so aufwendig wäre, ein Auge zu machen, deswegen machen die einen groten Punkt. Du hast dann, wie bei der Post, wo du so ein Kissen hast, wo du dann so die Dinger anweichst, so hast du so ein ganz kleines Schwärmischchen und dann so tup. Ich denke, die haben einfach so einen Pinsel an der Tür und wenn du rausgehst, läufst du eher dagegen und dann hast du so ein Ding aufgestimmt. Kann sein, das ist das dritte Auge. Warum die ist da und nicht am Finger, so vor dem Zeigefinger. So dass du hinter dich gucken kannst, wenn du möchtest? Ja, eben, am Zeigefinger kannst du überall hingucken, und das ist wie man sieht. Das ist viel kleinerer. Das stimmt, auch in die Zähne so, habe ich da noch was hinten? Ist da noch ein bisschen Meister drin? Wenn Evolution schneller gehen würde, Evolution haben wir schon ein paar Mal besprochen. Viel zu langsam. Ich habe herausgefunden, es ist ja einfach nur Mutationen, die sich dann besser fortpflanzen als andere. Und die aussterben, die es nicht haben. Ja, ja, ja. Und wenn Evolution schnell gehen würde, hätten wir doch einfach alle ein Auge auf dem Zeigefinger vorne. Der hat doch gewonnen, dieser Typ. Mit dem werden doch alle Frauen sofort schlafen, weil die sagen, diese Gene, die will ich weiter verteilen. Wie gut ist das denn, weil ein Auge vor... Warum zeigt der da hinten immer auf mich? Du kannst überall hingucken, du kannst um Ecken gucken, du kannst unten drunter gucken, du kannst hinter dich gucken.
Ja, aber wie funktioniert das? Siehst du dann das, was deine Augen sehen und das, was dein Finger sieht?
Oder hast du so eine Art Splitscreen oder so Bild im Bild?
Was glaubst du, was Ameisen haben, die 800 Augen haben, verschiedene, die sehen ja auch alles da.
Die haben halt wie so eine 360-Grad-Kamera, das können wir uns halt nicht vorstellen, aber naja.
Vor allem, wenn man unsere 63-Grad-Kamera sieht, haben die nur weirdes Bild. Die denken an, die laufen zu einem kleinen Planeten. Das sieht lustig aus. Nein, nein. So funktioniert das nicht, aber ich glaube, du verstehst. Naja, wenn du so ein Auge am Zeigefinger ist, das Beste. Das Problem ist der Sehnerv, dass der einfach nah am Gehirn sein muss. Ich glaube, wenn du Sehnerv durch den ganzen Arm verlegen musst, das ist eine Heimahre. Angenommen, man verliert die Hand, dann kriegt man eine Prothese und so. Kann man dann sagen, ich will aber nicht die Regalprothese, die Sie mal rauswinden. Du kannst dir dann für jeden Finger was aussuchen. Du kannst als fünf Slots und kannst dann irgendwie sagen, entweder mehr Akkulaufzeit. Auge, Auge, Nase, Ohr, Auge. Auge, Nase, Ohr, grosser Zeh. Nein! Kann ich es nochmal ändern? Nee, das haben sie jetzt so eingeloggt. Ah, fuck. Ja, wird es ja in Zukunft geben. Captain Hook zum Beispiel. Habe ich mir auch lange überlegt, warum der Haken? Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass es ja tatsächlich so Leute gibt, die so Amprothesen haben, die das aber abschrauben können. Wenn jetzt irgendwie sie kriegen Schokopudding, dann schrauben sie die Kettensäge ab. Kein Witz. Und schrauben sie den, der ist auch riesengroß, dann schrauben sie den Löffel und dann hopp. Wenn sie eine Geburtstag haben, kriegen sie so eine große Lolli draufgeschraubt. So eine Wunderkerze, Pfff, Wunderkerzen Flammenwerden. So eine Rammstein-Nummer, wo die einfach so Feuer von rauskommt. Ja, ja, ja. Ey, das ist ja gross eigentlich. und dann haben einfach Tante Erna ist gestorben, Sekunde, haben die so ein Set, so eine Hand, um sich dann so einen Kopf zu lagen, so, oh nein. Da gibt es ja hundertprozentig irgendwo eine Figur in einem Comic, die das hat, die sich immer erst die richtigen Sachen, die Gliedmassen schmutz. Wir haben ja heute auch mal über die Paralympics gesprochen.
Die Paralympics, die niemand interessiert und die eigentlich total geil sind.
Es sei denn, jemand bringt einen um. Dann haben wieder alle Interesse.
Kotz mich an sowas.
Aber die haben halt diese coolen, diese Weitspringer, die haben ja oft diese Beinprothesen.
Gibt es da nicht Milliarden Disziplinen?
Weil warum, also warum können die Downies nicht Weitspringen machen? Warum können die, weil die halt, die können auch allau, ich weiß nicht, die bestanden, wollen sie eine Gesten nicht machen hier. Aber warum machen die das nicht, die können auch, oder warum machen die nicht fechten? Warum ist denen nur vorbehalten zu schwimmen? Ja, weil die schwimmen wollen. Du kannst ja auch nicht sagen, ja gut, ich habe jetzt drei Beine, dann werde ich jetzt zu spinnen. Die sagen Wasser, Wasser, weil sie Durst haben, nicht weil sie ins Wasser wollen, glaube ich. Woran machst du fest, dass sie Bock haben zu schwimmen? Wer will eigentlich gewinnen, der also bei so einem 100-Meter-Sprint oder so, da treten ja immer so zehn Athleten an oder so was? Ja, aber die haben alle eine Behinderung, richtig? Ich meine jetzt bei der Normallympmpiade so, und nimm den schlechtesten und lass den antreten
gegen den besten aus den Paralympics.
Das würde ich mir
anschauen. Gut gegen böse,
dass sie halt einfach sie bekriegen
gegenseitig. Dass sie ineinander reinlaufen.
Ich stelle dir vor, der würde
verlieren gegen den Paralympics, selbst wenn ich auch denke,
alle trinieren mein ganzes Leben.
Aber ich habe mir Eintrachtquoten.
Gewinnt die Oscar-Pistorius-Leute, gewininnen die nicht einfach gegen die, weil die haben diese Prothesen, diese Samuel-Koch-Nummern, die können auch viel höher weiter springen und so. Samuel Koch auf Platz drei. Samuel Koch hat doch eine Kängurischuhe. Das sind doch nicht diese vier Phasenstiefel, die haben doch nicht die, doch stimmt, das ist nicht dasselbe. Können die nicht Kein Samuel Koch hätte auch aus dem Stand auf so ein Hausdach springen können? Weil die, wenn die richtig gebaut sind und so katapultähnlich, ein so da oben, weil du landest ja auch den Füssen. Ich glaube, wenn sein Vater ihm entgegengekommen wäre, hätte er das geschafft. Dann schafft er alles. Ich schaffe alles, solange mein Vater mir entgegenkommt. Hast du das damals live gesehen eigentlich? Nein. Ich hätte das live gesehen.
Aber da hat man auch alles gesehen. Ja, alles gesehen, dann haben sie aber angefangen,
dann relativ schnell haben sie so Tücher davor gehangen.
Wo haben die die Tücher her?
Die sind auf alles vorbereitet.
Decken, diese typischen,
diese goldenen Decken kriegt man auch immer umgehangen,
wenn man irgendwo einen Unfall mitbekommt.
Damit man cool aussieht.
Wie ein Opfer aus Filmen.
Damit wenn deine Frau dich identifizieren muss, sagt, ja, das ist er. Aber holy shit! Is cool! Ich glaube, die kommen auch so an. Wir haben das mal im Film gesehen. Dann hängen die einem das um und dann geht sie da weg. Wir wissen ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum die golden sind. Das ist krank. Das ist aber kein echtes Gold. Warmhalte. Ja, aber müssen die dafür extra golden sein? Nee, ich glaube, die können auch blau sein, aber es macht was her. Früher kann die Alufolie, dachte ich, immer hell warm. Ja, das ist doch, glaube ich, immer noch so. Wurde das nicht verhindert oder so? Aber hat sich Alufolie noch mal weiterentwickelt? Kriegt man ja nicht mit, als Otto-Normalverbraucher wie wir. Aber hat sich das noch mal weiterentwickelt? War es vor zehn Jahren genauso gut wie heute? Wo ist Schluss, ist da Schluss, ist Alufu das Beste, was wir herausbringen konnten? Ja, es gibt doch die, die so kleine Bärchen einprägniert haben. Da werden Schritte nach vorne gemacht. Das stimmt. Schon clever. Was ist... Beispiel, du hast noch einen schönen Schüssel Kartoffelsalat, ja, hast nicht alles gegessen, Irgendwie dein Date ist leider nicht erschienen, du hast noch einen schönen Schüssel Kartoffelsalat, hast nicht alles gegessen, irgendwie dein Date ist leider nicht erschienen, du hast alleine noch irgendwie drei Viertel reingedrückt und jetzt gilt es, das Ganze zu konservieren für den nächsten Tag. Bist du ein Frischhaltefolientyp oder Alufolientyp? Tupperguy. I'm the Tupperguy. Oh fuck. Oh shit. Klar, Tupperdose. Warum hast du welche dabei? Warum sind da Preisschien da dran? 18 Tupperdosen dabei. 18,99 Euro für die Große? Das ist aber, zeig mal. Tupperdose. Und wie viele Deckel sind da dabei? Ah, der Deckel hat so ein Fenster drin, da kannst du reingucken. Ich habe auch so Zipper, komm, gibst du noch Tupper auch? So musst du zippern, die sind ganz sind ganz toll. Tupper, die haben es auch richtig gemacht, mit den Events, die sie veranstalten. What? What? Das ist einfach nur eine Verpackungsfirma, die plötzlich so Events veranstaltet. Ich höre nur das Wort Event, da will mitmachen. Und kauft alles ein, was ihr habt. Hat sich der Erfinder von Tupper eigentlich beerdigen lassen in einem Tupper-Sarg? Das wäre konsequent. Das wäre ein Tweet vor allem. Hau mal raus, hau mal jetzt raus. Die Frage einfach nur. Einfach die Frage. Das ist doch kein Gag. Und wenn man nachschreibt, so ernsthaft, will ich wirklich wissen. Bitte schnell, ich bin allein gefangen im Zug. Das war immer der erste Gag beim Neo Magazin, die One-Liner für den Monolog, immer XY ist gestorben. So, der Erfinder von Twigs ist gestorben. Und dann der erste
Gag ist immer, er wurde
neben einem riesengroßen
Riegel begraben.
Ich frage mich, warum
du nicht so erfolgreich warst, als
vor in deiner Augen. Oder der Erfinder von Bounty
ist gestorben.
Wird er jetzt
wohl
am Boden einer Celebrationspackung begraben? Sowas in der Richtung, als jemand essen will. Wir glauben nicht, dass du nächstes Jahr noch dabei bist. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, okay, der Erfinder der Luftpumpe wurde begraben. Wird er jetzt mit zwei verschiedenen Ventilen begraben? Leute, bitte, meine Miete ... So, aber es ist einfach immer der erste Gag gewesen. Das stimmt. Der Erfinder vom Billiregal wurde, komm, das ist ein einfacher für dich. Der Erfinder vom Billiregal ist gestorben. Er musste vor dem Begraben erst zusammengebaut werden. Er wurde in als 64 Teile und einem Schraubschlüssel geliefert. Ich habe, glaube ich, geschrieben damals, Sie wollten, Sie haben den Sarg nicht zusammengebaut bekommen. sie wollten ihn erst begraben haben, den Sarg aber nicht zusammen. Sie haben den Sarg nicht zusammengebaut bekommen, aber ich glaube, gewonnen hat aber einer, der dann tatsächlich sich auf die Person gewonnen und der One-Liner des Tages. Der am wenigsten beschissene Gag. Es ist schon interessant, wie Witze funktionieren, machen wir uns auch Gedanken darüber. Ich glaube, es ist meistens einfach der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner. Ja, ein Lacher. Es ist immer das, was wirklich passiert ist, mit den ersten drei Assoziationen irgendwie verknüpft zu einem einigermassen, also Billigregal ist Schrauben nicht finden, nicht zusammenbauen können, Gebrauchsanleisung fehlt. Genau, Schwedisch, Ikea, Halt wieder zu Hause. Jetzt seht ihr da mal so rote Bindfäder mit einer großen Korkleinwand. So, und dann denkt euch mal, von diesen Worten müssen wir jetzt irgendwie zu etwas in der Mitte kommen und rechts ist diese Beerdigung. So, was ist dazwischen? Was ist zwischen Beerdigung und Gebrauchsanweisung fehlt? Sarg. Zack, und schon aus dem Gag. Gag ist es so. Das ist im Grunde funktioniert Humor. Du kannst einen ganzen Sketch schreiben, in dem du einfach zwei Welten kollidieren willst. Zwei Delfine wollen heiraten. So, jetzt nimmst du einfach alles, was du mit Delfinen assoziierst und alles, was du mit Heiraten assoziierst und kombinierst es. Sie dürfen die Braut jetzt so, und solche Gags ballest du einfach einen nach dem anderen raus. Dann gibt es halt keine grosse Torte, sondern halt irgendwie ganz viele von diesen dummen Fischen. Und dann schneiden die da rein. Und sowas, weißt du, dann kombinierst du einfach die Welten und schon hast du einen Sketch. Es ist simpel. Und ich glaube, die beste Comedy ist immer die, wo man das entweder auf diese Regel scheißt und einfach Erwartungen bricht, oder wo man nicht die ersten drei besten Erwartungshaltungen nimmt, sondern alles, was danach kommt. Im Grunde ist es dein Job, den vierten Einfall zu nehmen. Der Zuschauer kriegt ein, zwei, drei hin, aber du kriegst die vier auch noch hin. Und deswegen glaube ich ganz, ganz doll, dass Late-Night-Stand-Up eine Grenze hat. Weil alle Themen, die da kommen, sind meistens so Jenny Elvers, Lothar Matthäus, popkulturelle Themen, wo per Definition einfach nicht viele, weil die Leute sind nur bekannt und immer noch im Gespräch, weil sie so ein paar Dinge haben, so ein paar Assoziationen, die jeder damit verbindet. Beispiel Alkohol bei Jenny Elvers. Peter Altmaier ist dick. Genau, mehr weiss man über den aber auch gar nicht. Wie hieß er, Savatin? Ne, ähm. Sarrazin. Siberius, ne, wie hieß der pädophile? Ah, Sebastian Edati. Ah, Edati. Ja, genau. Und das sind immer, und deswegen, wie gesagt, der gemeinsame Nenner muss natürlich auch beim Publikum bekannt sein, und da diese ganzen Dinge nur aufgrund von ein, zwei Merkmalen bekannt sind überhaupt, kannst du halt nur mit den gleichen Gags machen. Was war zuerst da? Das Vorurteil oder der Gag? Verhärten, Gags, Vorurteile? Ja, voll! Und sobald du dann weiterkommst und die fünfte Assoziation nimmst, musst du aber schon dich eingelesen haben und dann weiss das Publikum nicht mehr. Was? Und wenn du anfängst, über Sebastian das Geburtsdatum Witze zu machen, weil das die achte Assoziation ist, gerade weil er Geburtstag hat, so und dann weiss aber niemand, wann hat der Geburtstag keine Ahnung so und dann fangen an, dass Leute am Publikum vorbei Witze machen. Und zur Not immer Wortspiele. Captain Cork. Weil du vorhin Cork gesagt hast. Captain Cork. Weil du vor acht Minuten Cork... Comedy ist Timing. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, und deswegen glaube ich, hat Late-Night-Stand-Up eine gewisse Grenze und deswegen wird es nicht besser. Das war eine These. Was? H Hau meine These raus. Jetzt ist meine These von dir. Ich habe tatsächlich, weil ich immer die One-Liner Probleme hatte mit dem One-Liner, ich habe mir irgendwann überlegt, ich schreibe einfach so Rezepte, so Formen, in die ich dann die Inhalte reindrücken kann. Der ganz klassischste Text, glaube ich, wo auch jeder zweite One-Liner ist, ist oder wie X sagen würde, Y. So, und dann kannst du immer, wenn du eine Feedline kriegst, die sind ja oft so als Feedlines formuliert, wie Oskar Siberius steht mit einem Fuss im Knast und dann Siberius steht mit einem Fuss in der Kälte. Und dann kannst du wieder sagen, ah, SPD hat 20 Prozent, oder wie Peter Altmaier sagen würde, fettarm. So, easy. Du kannst einfach wie sagen mit, ja, und dann habe ich mir überlegt, man macht lauter solche Formen. Ja, genau, dies ist eine Formel, beliebt ist auch, das ist ja genauso, als würde, mhm, mhm, mhm, das ist noch beliebt, dann gibt es so ein paar Regeln halt einfach. Oder der X von Y. Genau. Also der ist der, der, die, die... Der Peter Altmaier Finnlands. Ja, genau sowas. Aber das habe ich mir tatsächlich aufgeschrieben. Und mir sind noch ein paar eingefallen, auch sowas wie, also oft sind es so eine kleinere Sache, wie zum Beispiel das mit diesen, dass Inuit irgendwie 80 Worte für Schnee haben. Und dann kann es ja auch sagen, keine Ahnung, das Saarland hat 80 Worte für Schatz, deine Leine sieht heute super aus. So ein Kram halt, ne? Aber das funktioniert nicht immer, aber diese Inuit, nur wenn man jetzt auch sparen kann, das wäre genau der gleiche Gag gewesen, aber gut, klingt ein bisschen komplizierter. Warum sagst du dir einfach, Schatz, deine Leine, das ist einfach der Gag.
Warum diese Innoid, warum musst du bei allen Witz immer die Innoid mit reinziehen?
Ah, Muttertag im Saarland oder wie die Saarländer sagen würde, Schatz, deine Leine sieht heute toll aus.
Easy, es ist so leicht, es ist so einfach.
Ich muss halt sagen, du hast ein wahnsinnig knitteriges T-Shirt an, oder? Das stimmt. Das fällt auf. Das ist unfassbar knitterig. Ja, das stimmt. Ich bin gerade umgezogen tatsächlich. Ja, das sieht man. Bei niemandem sieht man das so doll wie bei dir. Und ich habe echt das Krasseste, was es gibt. Und zwar bin ich umgezogen und ich habe relativ viele von meinem Vormieter übernommen. Und ich finde auch immer noch so kleine Sachen von meinem Vormieter, was ganz interessant ist. Oh, ein zweites Badezimmer! Und Moment mal, diese Wand, wenn man eine Bombe davor legt, entsteht ein Loch und man kommt in einen zweiten Raum. Was er mir hinterlassen hat, ist eine Waschmaschine. Langweilig, hab ich auch, hab ich auch. Hab ich nicht. Nope, Waschmaschine plus Trockner. Du tust da deine Sachen rein, die sind dreckig. Und dann werden die gewaschen und dann werden die getrocknet, und dann kommen die trocken und sauber raus. Trockensauber und knitterig. Ja, aber ultra knitterig. Meine Kleidung, es sieht einfach schrecklich aus. Ich sehe einfach aus wie so eine Zeitung. Früher hatte ich so eine Felika aufgetätigt. Gerade man in dieses, ich kann nicht mehr mit meinen Pokémon-Shirts abends
man ging auch mal feiern, dann gab es
diese ersten alkoholfreien Feten, bei uns
dieses damals Dancevotum, das war
in der Stadthalle immer, da konnte man abends hingehen
der Latein-El-Karlit-Ein
das Spektakulum
Votum
ja und dann kam ich in dieses
Hemdzeitalter und da habe ich einen Fehler kaputtiert
und ich habe so ein Knitterhemd angezogen
die waren dann so knitterig, oh das war
so eklig, so kariert, ich weiß nicht, es war
Die Ja, und dann kam ich in dieses Hemdzeitalter und da habe ich einen Fehler kaputt gemacht, ich habe ein Knitterhemd angezogen, die waren dann so knitterig, das war so eklig, ich weiß nicht, das war lila kariert knitterig, das war so eklig und man musste das, um diese Knitteroptik beizubehalten, mit Tennisbällen waschen, in einer Waschmaschine. Warum, du wolltest die Knitteroptik behalten? Nee, das Hemd wollte die Knitteroptik behalten. Ach so. Das Hemd stand drauf, stand drauf halt. Ich bestehe, Alter, sonst bin ich weg, ey. Ich bestehe auf Tennisbälle, wenn ich gewaschen werde.
Naja, und das war echt, und so sieht es ein bisschen jetzt aus, dein weisse Shirt mit seinem Knitteroptik.
Ey, das wird sich aber auch so durchziehen, das ist einfach lächerlich für alles, aber es ist ultra praktisch, weil es einfach so voll trocken ist.
Bügeleisen, klassisch Bügeleisen.
Das ist grossartig, Bügeleisen.
Das ist aber auch so, schön langsam, das ist ja immer so das Klischee, dass man ha ha ha so peinlich, dass man sich mit 30 noch ein Bügelbrett kauft, weil dann weiß jeder, dass man es davor nie gebraucht hat. Aber so wird es bei mir sein. Ich werde irgendwann mal einen Oscar gewinnen und dann werde ich sagen so, oh, Clooney, ich komme gleich, die Limousine liegt vor meiner Wohnung, ciao Clooney und dann fange ich an noch schnell mein Smoking
zu bügeln.
Und dann geht es ab nach Los Angeles.
Brum, brum, brum.
Das ist deine
Vorstellung von Reichtum,
dass du noch schnell deinen Smoking
bügeln musst. Ja,
meinen teuren Smoking. Warum gehst du nicht
in die Reinigung? Ja, weil da muss ich
mit anderen Menschen reden. Warum lässt du dich nicht von deinem Lakaien Cloi in die Reinigung bringen? Da muss ich mit meinem Lakaien sprechen. Mein Lakaikai. Kai! Das ist doch bestimmt Lakaien, der mit deinem Lakaien spricht. Ich wäre gerne so richtig reich. Ja, aber was bedeutet Reichtum für dich? Was ist der Punkt? Freundschaft, viele Freunde. Nee, massenmal viel Geld. Sehr viel Geld, fünf Millionen, die man auch so ausgeben kann. Aber versuch es anders auszudrücken, versuch zu sagen, reich ist für mich dann, wenn ich nicht mehr sowas in der Richtung. Reich ist für mich dann, wenn ich beim Tätigen von Lustkäufen nicht mehr auf meinen Kontostand trinken muss. Tust du das denn momentan, dass du, wenn du dir dein Boosted Board kaufst? Ja, weil es theoretisch mein ganzes Erspartes in den Ruinen treiben muss. Kleines Recap, wie oft hast du dein Boosterboard benutzt, seitdem du es gekauft hast? Du meinst du seit nach oder bevor ich hingefallen bin? Nach dem Ereignis. Also vor dem Ereignis bin ich dreimal gefahren und nach dem Ereignis bin ich noch einmal gefahren. Einmal noch. Es war ein Weißt du, wenn man als Kind ein Ereignis erlebt, dann kann es einen auch traumatisieren. Dann macht man das nicht mehr. Wenn ich in Wahl beißt, dann kannst du nicht mehr lange mit, dann kannst du nicht mit. Du bist auch mit deinem Hoverboard in deiner Wohnung gestürzt und warst ihm dann seitdem nicht mehr vertraut und es passiert das exakt selbe, was ich dir auch prophezeit habe beim Boosted-Bot. Und du, nein, nein, ich werde ja mit jedem Tag zur Arbeit boosten. Ich würde mal so, man sagt ja manchmal so, das Leben schreibt die spannendsten Geschichten. Nein. Stephen King schreibt spannende Geschichten, das Leben schreibt vorhersehbare Geschichten. Das Leben, dass ich davon runterfalle, dass ich nicht mehr berühre, war vorhersehbar. Das ist eine Storyline, die ich nicht mehr akzeptiere. Du bist vor allem ein uninteressanter Charakter, weil du dich nicht veränderst, du lernst nicht aus deinen Fehlern. Ich bin ein Sitcom-Charakter. Du bist ein Sitcom-Charakter. Ich bin vor der Folge genauso wie am Ende der Folge. Das stimmt. Aber du erledest immer ein Problem. Und das du löst, aber dann immer noch unglücklich bist. Aber einen Film guckst du zweimal, höchstens, durchschnittlich. Aber ein gutes Sitcom, die kannst du immer gucken. Was? Ich glaube, man schaut sich eher Filme nochmal an als Serien. Nicht die ganze Sitcom, aber du kannst dir mehr Folgen angucken. Ich bringe immer wieder neue Folgen raus, wo ich danach genauso bin wie am Anfang. Ja, einfach nur um Werbung zu verkaufen. Da ist ja nichts dahinter. Ja, genau. Ich bin eine Sitcom, die hauptsächlich für die Werbung zwischendurch da ist. Du willst doch mal irgendwas beenden, du willst doch mal irgendwo hinkommen. Eine Aussage haben. Morgen muss ich zum Ikea, morgen muss ich neue Sachen kaufen, morgen schließe ich. Liebst du nicht, ey, ich wollte in den USA unbedingt zum Ikea, weil ich dachte mir, wie geil, weil man hat ja in den USA, also ich kann das nicht leugnen, ich habe manchmal so eine gewisse Form von Heimweh, weil es eine ganz andere Kultur ist und du vermisst manchmal einfach Dinge, die du kennst und es ist ganz normal, ganz menschlich und da ist einfach sehr viel sehr anders. Und manchmal das Gefühl zu gehen in einen Laden, den du kennst und dieser Geruch, ich will wissen, ist der Geruch in Ikea Amerika genau der gleiche wie in Deutschland. Weil jeder Ikea in Deutschland riecht exakt gleich. Ich glaube, das ist auch der Erfolg von diesen ganzen Ketten, dass sie alle gleich sind, auch alle Aldis sehen gleich aus, alle Lidl sehen gleich aus. Und hast einfach Bock, immer wieder dasselbe zu machen, der Mensch ist einfach, wird alles wiederholen, aber es stimmt, ich gehe von morgen zu mir kehr und ich freue mich drauf, es ist immer ein Erlebnis und man steht ja irgendwie, wenn man umzieht, steht man immer vor der Wahl, sich zu überlegen, hm, soll meine Wohnung jetzt exakt genauso aussehen, wie die von allen anderen oder individuell? Und am Ende sage ich mir, nee, die soll schon exakt genauso aussehen, wie alle. Ich habe genau diese Gläser, die auch hier stehen, die Gläser, die jeder hat, diese Gläser, dieses erfolgreichste Design aller Zeiten. Jeder weiß, welche Gläser ich meine. Die habe ich dann auch. Nee, ich glaube nicht. Doch, jeder weiß, Ikea-Gläser weiß jeder. Beschreibt mal jetzt gerade die Gläser, die ihr meint, die Flutten gerade meint. Ja, sagt das jetzt mal laut vor euch hin. Sagt mal jetzt, beschreibt mal gerade, welches Glas ihr meint. Jetzt mal den Podcast an. Genau. Und dann schreibt mal in die Kommentare. Jetzt haben die schon angehalten. Toll, was soll ich mir jetzt noch sagen? Hey! Hey! Macht mal noch mal an! Mach wieder weiter! Macht nochmal... Wir warten kurz. Scheiße. Die sind gleich wieder da. Leute, wie leis es ist. Ist niemand mehr da. Wie leis es ist. Hör mal hin. Ist niemand mehr da. Wir sind völlig alleine. So. Malt mal einfach auf die Gläser, die ihr meint. Oder sucht mal ein Bild raus und schickt uns das bei Twitter, Spotify, Instagram und so. Ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass wir die gleiche Vorstellung des Glases haben.
Aber ich freue mich da auch drauf, immer, weil Ikea ist sowas, aber auf der anderen Seite, ich habe Ikea schätzen gelernt, als ich dann eingezogen bin in meine Wohnung, weil es einfach alles günstiger ist und sehr einfach und du kannst es mitnehmen und aufbauen und du hast schnell Möbel einfach. Aber irgendwann nervt es.
Nach und nach habe ich Ikea-Dinge wieder ausgetauscht
durch ein bisschen wertigere, coolere Möbelstücke,
die ein bisschen was hermachen, wo du einfach so ein bisschen Individualität spürst. Ich verstehe. Aber es hat auch immer sowas für einen Umbruch. Man zieht um und dann fährt man zu Ikea und Ikea hat immer so was von Neuanfang. So, ah, jetzt geht's neu los und ich decke mich noch komplett neu ein und ich kaufe neue Bettwäsche und alles. Endlich wieder Single, geil. Ja, cool, endlich wieder los, endlich kein Geld mehr, um das ich mir Sorgen machen muss. Es geht einfach alles von vorn aus, aber du bist ja auch auf der Suche in einer neuen Wohnung momentan. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir sind völlig im Umbruch. Ich weiß. In Boosted Board Reichweite oder was oder wo? Genau, das ist vor allem die Idee. Ich will jetzt hier näher an die Firma auch ran, weil es ist besser, weil ich muss immer, es ist morgens echt nervig, immer Bahn fahren und eine halbe Stunde lang bin ich unterwegs. Ja, muss ich ja jetzt auch, aber ich will mein Fahrrad holen. Ja, das ist auch weit weg vom Dom. Nö, das ist 15 Minuten oder so. Ja gut, das ist schon eine Strecke, aber fährst du jeden Morgen Fahrrad, kommst du wach an. Aber das ist auch was, ich glaube, um deine Frage von vor drei Stunden zu beantworten, ich wäre gerne so reich, dass ich mir gute Möbel kaufen kann.
So ein Eames-Chair.
Weil ich weiß, die ist gar nicht wichtig, wie du wohnst.
Du hast auch kein Gefühl für Ordnung oder so, ist dir alles scheißegal.
Du ekelst dich auch nicht doll.
Ich muss mich oft mit schönen Dingen umgeben.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass meine Wohnung schön aussehen muss.
Sonst werde ich unglücklich. Kauf dir einen Spiegel. Ich hab jetzt die Formel 1 für mich entdeckt. Was ein cooler Sport. Was für ein fucking langweiliger Scheissport. Was ein cooler, geiler Sport. Ich finde das total beeindruckend. Alles daran ist beeindruckend, wirklich. Auch am Wochenende gab es einen enormen Crash direkt am Start. Und dann hast du ja quasi der Fahrer, der die ganze Arbeit macht, und dieses Team. Gut, dieses Team macht vielleicht die ganze Arbeit. Aber dann hast du halt so einen Mechaniker, der einmal pro 90 Minuten Rennen rausrennen muss, eine Reifen in der Hand hat, drauf macht und weg macht, möglichst schnell, und dann ist er durch. Dann ist er für den ganzen Tag durch. Und dann fliegt er mit dem ganzen Team weiter, mit so lächerlich riesigen Bussen, die gar nicht mehr aussehen wie Busse, sondern wie Häuser, fährt er dann irgendwie von Singapur nach Malaysia fürs nächste Rennen, wo er dann wieder einmal den Reifen draufschieben muss. Machen die auch noch was anderes an dem Auto? Ich glaube, die halten da schon den Stand und er kümmert sich halt auch um die Reifen und analysiert vielleicht die Strecke, welche Art von Reifen man da braucht oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Kümmer sich doch um das Genugreifen. Früher mussten die doch die Reifen aussuchen und so. Mittlerweile haben die alle die gleichen Reifen. Hast du irgendeine Sportart, die du für dich entdeckt hast, oder ist das für dich Tribialer Bullshit? Echt nur E-Sport, wenn ein Booter eigentlich E-Sport, aber ansonsten mehr, mehr eigentlich nicht, das interessiert mich nicht, finde ich nicht so interessant. Aber tatsächlich, ich habe Gran Turismo habe ich früher gern gespielt, das fand ich schon interessant, dann so die Strecke so perfekt zu fahren und dann ein Hundertstel von Sekunden rauszuholen. Das hat schon Spaß gemacht, aber tatsächlich würde ich mir bei Formel 1 immer so denken, so, ne, Leute, das verbrennt nicht so viel Benzin. Ja, man hat auch Elektromotoren. Ja, nicht nur noch, aber vor allem, wie langweilig dieser Sport wäre, wenn du einfach so schwebende Elektromotoren da hast, die einfach keinen Geräusch mehr machen. Aber das erste Bussebordrennen dann einfach. Mega geil, und ich glaube, es wird unfassbar erfolgreich irgendwann mal, sind Drohnen-Racings. Habe ich schon lange prophezeit. Ich glaube, das wird der nächste richtig krasse Rennsport. Ja, wenn die Leute sich auch richtig so ein bisschen Set-Design-Mühe geben, dann so eine Eiswelt und so eine Vulkanwelt und wie bei so Minigolf oder so eine große Mühle dann so dreht. Diese Quadrocopter. Also durchfahren, mega geil. Quadro oder Quadrocopter? Quadro, Quadrocopter. Kann so was sein, aber die sind halt irritierend laut. Unfassbar aus. Ja, aber Formel 1 fangen ja auch, aber das ist geil. Aber die sind cool. Wenn du dann im, ja, die Drohnen, die fliegen, hallo, die fliegen schnell rum. Da gibt es halt im Wembley-Stadion, wo das, glaube ich, mal gemacht, da haben die das ausgebaut und halt rechts so kleine Hindernisse gebaut, wo man durch musste. Und dann haben die das halt gezeigt, so in Split-Screens, was die Piloten sehen, die einfach so eine VR-Brille auf hatten und dann diese Drohne First-Person steuern. Das ist einfach unglaublich cool, das ist einfach richtig cool. Und die können sich ja auch so berühren und dann fliegt eins raus und so weiter. Und dann kann ein Team das wieder reparieren und muss dann da wieder rein. Können auch so Bananen legen, wo die anderen dann reinfahren und dann ist der Bahn geschleuert. Richtig. Das ist richtig cool. Was war der letzte Sport, der ausgestorben ist, wo wir Leute gesagt haben so, so Leute, packen wir zusammen, wir sind der letzte Verein, hier ist Schloss. Gibt es einen Sport, wo es nur noch einen Verein gibt, irgendwie so Hochball, man muss den Ball möglichst hochwerfen, sondern da gibt es noch einen Verein in ganz Deutschland und die sagen, der Nachwuchs stirbt aus, wir haben jetzt eigentlich nur noch Clara, Clara ist die einzige, solange du noch Bock hast, machen wir weiter. Sie zahlt monatlich die Beiträge, aber das war es auch. Sie gut ist sie nicht. Clara wird jetzt auch älter irgendwie, hat jetzt auch angefangen, Karriere zu spielen. Clara kann den Ball nicht so hochwerfen wie die meisten Menschen. Durchschnittlich können die meisten Menschen den Ball höher werfen als Clara. Der normale Mensch, der normale Passant kann den Ball höher werfen als Clara. Aber trotzdem gewinnt sie eine Goldmedaille nach der anderen, weil sie die fucking einzige im Hochball ist. Danke Clara, dass du diesen Sport auch leben hältst. Sie wirft auch die Technik, ihre Technik ist nicht immer gut. Herr Grevenfeld, ich möchte jetzt nicht mehr zum Training kommen. Was? Ich spiele das Klavier und ich habe jetzt den Ronald kennengelernt. Was? Der macht mir schöne Augen und deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht mehr kommen. Das ist eine sehr eigentümliche Ausdrucksweise. Warum kannst du nicht einfach jetzt aufhören? Du bist unser letzter Nachwuchs. Nach dir kommt gar nichts mehr, Hochball schiebt aus. Ich möchte nicht ... Ich habe jetzt nicht in der Schule so viel zu tun, mit Alchemie und Aradrhythmus und Arithrea, da habe ich so viel zu tun. Bevor wir in dieser unsicheren, ich weiß nicht genau, in welcher unsicheren Zeit wir uns befinden, aber nimm kurz diesen Ball, bevor du weitersprichst, nimm diesen Ball, werf ihn einmal nochmal, so hoch du kannst und dann sag mir, dass du diesen Sport nicht weitermachen willst. Ich habe morgen Arithmetik-Prüfung, aber gut. Es ist elf Meter, das ist nicht so viel, Herr Grevenfeld. Das ist nicht so hoch, Clara. Ich weiß auch nicht, wofür wir die letzten fünf Jahre getrainiert haben. Es tut mir leid, meine Arme sind so schwach. Mit dir stimmt der ganze Sport aus. Es tut mir leid. Hochball. Das war Hochball, Rest in Peace. 1408 bis 1609. Ich frage mich bei Ultimate Frisbee, warum man deinen Schluss durchgezogen hat. Warum man da gesagt hat, das ist jetzt Ultimate Frisbee. Wo ist Hyper Ultimate Frisbee? Die haben einfach das Gefühl gehabt, sie mussten ihre Sportler noch ein bisschen cooler benennen. Die Abstufung, es gibt Frisbee und dann Ultimate Frisbee. Ja, dazwischen gibt es nicht. Was ist denn mit Cool Frisbee, Super Frisbee, Mega Frisbee? Meinetwegen Okay Frisbee. Ja. Meinetwegen Average Frisbee. Wir sind die Average-Leute, die man ein bisschen rumwerfen soll. Is there really nothing better Frisbee? Einfach sowas. Frisbee ist auch, wenn diese Bewegung nicht so lächerlich wäre. Du könntest dich auch so andrehen, dass hier so um die Leute herum. Jaft ja von oben. Stefan ist einer dieser von oben. Ja, einer als unser scheiß Kollege, dem jemand zugeflogen ist, vor die Füsse und er dann so von außen, diese Aussentechnik. Oh, wie uncool. Aber er hat schon echt hart geworfen, er war schon stark. Er war schon echt gut und er hat uns auch getroffen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Ja, Frisbee, wir hatten immer diesen coolen Ring, diesen Xena-Ring. Wir hatten mal diesen Ring, den haben wir uns nochmal nachgekauft, der ist mittlerweile auch weg, aber dann haben wir auf dem Hof haben wir dann Frisbee gespielt.
Muss man sich vorstellen, so ein schöner Sommertag, wir sind rausgegangen, hatten nicht so viel zu tun, haben uns zugeworfen.
Hey, Flutin, hier, her, hab ich, da, Stürrück, Stürrück, Stürrück, Schäfer, was, nein, da kommt er, nein, er hat eine Linksdrehung gemacht, eine Linksdrehung gemacht und ist dann zu den Nachbarn rüber, wo man nur so Bäume gesehen hat. Wir, ach shit, egal, komm, besorgen wir uns, finden wir schon. Wir haben uns beide auf ein Fahrrad, was nicht uns gehört, geschmissen und dann reingetrappelt. Und du bist auf so einem Damenfahrrad, so ein kleines Damenfahrrad mit so einer Fahne hinten dran und wir sind losgeradelt. Und dann einmal um die Mauer rum, hinten an der Strasse lang, dann wieder zurück. Und dann waren wir in einer ganz merkwürdigen Parallelwelt. Ganz kleine Menschen haben da gewohnt und gearbeitet an einem Brunnen. Ich verstehe dieses, also alles war bewuchert, so moosartig, efeuartig bewuchert. Und dann waren da so kleine Häuser und die waren so flach gebaut überall. Ganz klein, auch alle nur einstöckig. So ganz klein und kein Mensch da. Und dann war niemand da. Und keine Autos, aber alle Fenster waren irgendwie offen. Da war gerade schon niemand. Und dann sind wir da hin und dann lag unsere Frisbee. Das war nicht zu finden. Und am nächsten Tag bin ich noch mal hingegangen und dann stand die fein säuberlich hingestellt an einem der Häuserwände.
Immer noch niemand da.
Bei Familie Beutlin hat es dann vor die Tür gestellt.
Mit Ringe haben sie es einfach.
Dann haben wir es wieder genommen, den Ring abgenommen.
Ganz im Ernst, was war das denn für eine Welt?
Was für Gargoyles
haben da denn gelebt eigentlich? Ganz merkwürdig.
Aber es gibt ganz viele Parallelwelten,
von denen man nichts weiß.
Das fand ich auch in New York so toll, wo gegenüber von uns diese orthodoxen Juden gewohnt haben. Und dann auch so ganz verschiedene Kulturen, wo man das Gefühl hat, da geht jedem gerade ein ganz anderes Business. Nur noch so eine Karte an der Tür vorne kleben, so ein Pik Ass. Ich war auch die Frage, okay, gut, was ist das jetzt genau? Und dann jemals ein ganz anderes eigenes Business, mit ganz eigenen Problemen, aber auch eigenen Lösungsansätzen. Das ist echt ganz verrückt, ne? Es gibt verschiedene Menschen auf der Erde. Das ist echt... Wenn man mal die Erkenntnisse vom Podcasthof zusammenfasst, am Ende eines solchen Bits. Eins ist grösser als null. Wow, ihr habt schon recht. Das ist schon krass. Das stimmt schon. Ich habe einen Filmtipp rauszuhauen, weil ich wirklich nachhaltig beeindruckt bin von diesem Film. Du hast ihn auch gesehen und wir haben beide am Wochenende zufällig unabhängig voneinander gesehen. Geht auf jeden Fall, und ich möchte euch da einfach bitten, das einfach zu machen und euch da vor nichts mehr durchzulesen, einfach reingehen, einfach mal blind reingehen. Geht in Mother von Darren Aronofsky. Ein neuer Film, Mother Ausrufezeichen. Darren Aronofsky. Darren Aronofsky. Darren Aronofsky. Und der, kennt ihr vielleicht, Black Swan hat er gemacht, Noah hat er gemacht, Life of Pie hat er gemacht, American Pie hat er gemacht. House of Pies. Das ist der abgefahrenste Film, den ich jemals gesehen habe. So viel sei gesagt, das Kino war, ich habe mich gefreut, als jemand, der oft ins Kino geht und der sich oft über Leute abfuckt, die im Kino sind, war dieser Film eine Genugtuung. Weil ich sass da drin, hab diesen Film geguckt, genossen, auch nicht wirklich genossen, ich war auch teilweise echt verstört, aber das ganze Kino um mich herum war so wütend, dass sie dafür diese 8,50 Euro ausgegeben haben. Die waren so angepisst, manche sind aufgestanden, während der Vorstellung rausgegangen, was ich auch noch nie erlebt habe, manche haben die ganze Zeit gerufen, was ein furchtbarer Film, was ein furchtbarer Film! Wem sagst du das? Zu wem sprichst du? Da haben sie recht! Die ganze Zeit, dann Kinder wurden mit reingenommen, was ich gar nicht verstanden habe, die wurden auch ganz schnell verstört rausgenommen. Ja, das war einfach eine unfassbare Erfahrung, das war echt eine Genugfung für mich, fand ich. Einfach mal so wütend, dass er die Leute wütend gemacht hat. Der Film wird auch sehr kontrovers diskutiert, es gibt sehr viele sehr schlechte Bewertungen, auch ein paar gute. Auch sehr viele sehr gute, ja. Aber es ist schon mal interessant, dass er auch so was auslösen kann. Ansonsten ist ein schlechter Film einfach langweilig, aber es gibt auch Filme, also entweder so schlecht oder die einen einfach so beeindrucken, ohne jetzt eine Wertung zu haben oder einfach angeben. Ja, aber da muss man mal, ich finde, das ist auch so ein Film, das Werte-Muster, auch dieses Eins von Zehn und so, was mittlerweile im Internet so gängig ist, wenn man so ein bisschen über den Haufen wirft, weil was ist daran jetzt, also dem würde ich dem würde ich da auf dieser Skala eine Zehn von Zehn geben, weil keine Ahnung, was die jetzt genau besagt. Wie unterhaltsam der Film war, wie inwiefern das als ein Kunstwerk zu bewerten ist, als ein fucking Milestone, den man auf jeden Fall mal gucken sollte, ist ja die Frage. Also der wirft das alles so ein bisschen durcheinander. Auch die Art, die man über Filme spricht. Und auch dann bin ich mit Deut auf dem Kino gegangen und mich nervt das immer einfach, wie die darüber reden. Aber bei diesem Film fand ich es so toll, dem zuzuhören. Weil die alle so abgefuckt waren darüber. Und so sauer über diesen Film. Und auf das Kino und auf alles. Es war einfach interessant zu sehen. Wir haben das Kino hassen gelernt. Nächste Woche können wir mal über den Inhalt sprechen. Mit Anna Frebel. Mit Anna Frebel. Die wahrscheinlich nächste Woche am Start ist. Wir haben es endlich geschafft. Wir haben uns wieder zurück ins Game gebaselt. N Und nächste Woche ist es soweit. Wir haben schon ein paar coole Fragen von euch bekommen. Und die werden wir Frau Professorin Frebel stellen und über das Universum diskutieren. Ganz kurz mal ein Teaser. Ihr habt doch einfach einen kompletten Vollschaden. Fragen aus der Community waren zum Beispiel, was erhoffen Sie sich vom JWST? Mhm, dankeschön. Dann hier eine
bisher unbekannte Klasse von schwarzen Löchern.
Wie viel beeinflusst die Erkenntnis die aktuellen Paradigmen
der Galaxieformation, der Formation von
grossgeiligen Strukturen?
Das sind doch nur Poser,
die klatschen doch irgendwie gerade in den Worten.
Dann stellen wir die Fragen und sie sagt sowas wie,
das mag keinen Sinn ergeben gerade.
Erde, Antimaterie, ist höhere Macht,
so, dankeschön. Das sind Fragen auf meinem Miveau. Gibt es Gott, oder was? Gibt es einen Gott? Können wir drüber reden, können wir drüber reden, ich freue mich drauf, es wird vielleicht das peinlichste, vielleicht das interessanteste, aber auf jeden Fall lehrreichste Gespräch, dass wir alle jemals finden, hast du ein Gespräch in deinem Leben geführt, auf das du zurückblickst und sagst so, wow, das war ein echt gutes Gespräch? Nee, weil immer wenn es mir wichtig war, habe ich es verkackt, also so gefühlt, weil dann steckt man so viel, da ist man auch so nervös und so. Ich habe halt, damals war ich ein Riesen, war ich so ein Dan Brown, ich hinterfrag Religionphase, wo ich so 14 war oder so. Da fand ich das cool, da kam halt so Illuminati raus und Sakrilegis fand ich alles ganz cool. Da gab es unsere erste Hausarbeit, musste man machen, da habe ich dann mit einem Priester gesprochen und einem Wissenschaftler von CERN. Das war cool, das war damals ein richtig cooles Gespräch, wo ich damals so richtig beeindruckt war, weil ich den halt so antimaterie Sachen gefragt habe und so. Das war einfach ein cooler Typ von CERN einfach, der mit sau viel Ahnung hatte und ich mit meinen naiven Dan Brown-Fragen halt voll aufgelaufen bin.
Aber fand ich auch einen tollen Film, den ersten Film fand ich echt gut. Also natürlich ist das viel Bullshit und so, ja natürlich ist das viel Bullshit und so, Quatsch, aber als Film, ich mag auch diese Filme, auch so, das so Neun Pforten und so fand ich auch einen guten Film und dann hier mit, ja wo Johnny Depp dieses Buch hat und so, was irgendwie so in Büchern und Bibliotheken und starb auch so die die die purpuren Flüsse und so. Oh, die purpuren Flüsse mag ich auch sehr gerne. Richtig geiler Film. Purpur- den Flüsse? Die mag ich richtig gern, ja. Joe Reno! Heute ist Joe Reno! Es sind richtig coole Leute. Schaut euch heute mal einfach die purpuren Flüsse an. Ich laufe noch andauernd auf ProSieben. Das ist einfach so ein zeitloses Ding. Purpullenflüsse eins und zwei. Zwei weiss ich nicht mehr, aber... Doch, die sind beide nicht schlecht. Mit dem Mönch? Aber da kommt der Skeptiker Florentin. Nein, nimm ihn weg! Der Skeptiker Florentin ist da. Der Heckenscheren Florentin. Ah, nee, nee. Viele Leute haben Bilder von ihren Hunden geschickt, die reagiert haben auf unser Weff, Weff. Und tatsächlich hat das einen grossen Effekt bei Hunden. Also anscheinend haben wir hier den Hundekot geknackt, den Da-Doggy-Kot. Oh Gott, das ist manchmal einfach nicht einfach. Das ist manchmal zu schwer. Manchmal legt man, manchmal stellst du dir selbst ein Bein. Doch manchmal lochst du ein. Tag, Tag. Im Sinne von Fußball. So ein Kinder... Ey, vor allem das Lyrics, die es selbst erklärt. Ist Rolf zu Kopski eigentlich jemand in so eine Pädofalle getippt? Also als jemand, der... Ey, wenn du so viele Group so viele Groupies hast, tippst du automatisch in diese Pornofalle. Hat er, glaubst du, weibliche Fans, die mehr von ihm wollen, die aber erst sechs sind? Die dann so Hello Kitty-Unterhosen auf die Bühne werfen. Er so, Leute, das ist hochgradig illegal, die Fotos sind ... Ah, nein! Ich hab's berührt. Ah, scheiße, ah, das ist ... Naja, jetzt ist es auch egal. Rolf Zukowski, der schreibt so viele Lieder mit so vielen Texten, dass da nicht mal so eine Zweideutigkeit rausrutscht ihm, wo der Verfassungsschutzer auch sagt, ups, sorry, da müssen wir nochmal nachschauen. Oder so in Musikvideos, gibt es eigentlich Musikvideos zu Rolf Zukowski-Liedern? Ja, ja, klar. In der Weihnachtsbäckerei, wo so Puderzucker über so Kinder streut und dann so ableckt? Gibt's das?
Das würde ich gern sehen.
Und dann so, der Zuckerberguss durch den Raum fliegt in Laras Gesicht.
Schau mal.
In der Weinerzweckerei gibt es manche Schweinerei.
Zwischen Mehl und Milch hat so mancher Knill, ich gleicht mein Riesenschwängel in der Hand.
Ich glaube, das ist der Moment, wo der Polka-Sufo auf dem Index.
Ey, aber bald ist ja wieder Weihnachtszeit, ich habe richtig Bock auf Weihnachten.
Und ich freue mich, wenn die Flocken wieder vom Himmel strömen und der Plätzchengeruch durch die Strassen weht.
Ich habe richtig Bock auf Weihnachten und ich freue mich, wenn die Flocken wieder vom Himmel strömen und der Plätzchengeruch durch die Strassen weht. Ich habe richtig Bock drauf, endlich ist die Sonne weg. Ja, geh mal, Alter. Ne, 19 Sekunden ist frei. Das ist einfach falsch. Es werden immer mehr, es waren mal drei Sekunden. Ne, acht und vier Minuten gehen, mehr nicht. Aber ich glaube, ich glaub, wenn, doch, das heißt, hier gibt es so eine Regel.
Nein.
Doch, gibt es wirklich. Ich hab wirklich von jemandem gehört, dass diese Regel Bullshit ist.
Ich bin ein Genie, ich weiss Dinge.
Du musst deine Bachelorarbeit nicht immer hochhalten.
Hast du die immer dabei?
Ja, da steht drauf, Bachelor of Arts.
Ja, vier Komma drei, was ist das für eine Note?
Off Arts.
Ist eigentlich Off Arts auch schon, vielleicht so Off Science, noch hier hat er einmal Off Science, er hätte schon gewonnen. Journalismus ist weder Science noch Arts, von daher fuck it. Vor allem angenommen, es würde gehen, diese 19-Sekunden-Regel, dann könnte man es dann wieder ausmachen und dann wieder anmachen. Das Video ist weird. Natürlich ist es weird. Bauen wir mal einen Schneemann dieses Jahr? Erst mal so einen richtig großen Schneemann bauen. Erstmal müssen wir, das machen wir, in diesem Winter machen wir dich fit, genau das lustig, weil dann beginnt die Hallensaison. Skifahren! Ich dachte, wir gehen schön powdern. Du auf dem Boosted Snowboard? Nee, ich bin klassischer Skifahrer. Ja? Snowblader. Bist du Snowboard oder Skifahren? Snowblader, schön powderader. Du kriegst mit deinem massigen Körper das Ding gar nicht rumgerissen. Was? Snowblades ist genau dafür da. Snowblades? Die sind kurz, die sind 99 cm lang. Diese Skates, diese Schuhe, Schlittschuhe meinst du? Nein, Snowblades sind Ski, die 99 cm lang sind. Warum nicht die 100? Ab einem Meter braucht man so eine Gebinde. Binde, Bindung. Wie heißt das? Bindung. Ja, eine Skibindung. Auf jeden Fall Snowblades sind eine heiße Scheiß, Leute, haltet eure Augen auf. Nächste Woche geht es weiter mit Anna Frebel, wir freuen uns sehr darauf und Stefan wird weiterhin trainieren. Ja, und wir haben vergessen, die Emojis zu pitchen. Ah, Scheiße! Das machen wir nächste Woche. Und ich habe noch acht Thema-Ballisten. Ich weiß nicht, wir haben so rumgeschwarven, Leute. Naja. Das machen wir nächste Woche mit Anna Frebel. Vielleicht hat sie auch ein Ocho dabei. Das machen wir danach einfach. So ein Kern, so ein LHC. Das ist eigentlich ein grosser Donut. Im Grunde ist es ein grosser Donut. Vor allem, wo wir gerade Bachelor arbeiten, vielleicht ein Kumpel von mir hat einen Physik-Bachelor gemacht. Und die haben so einen kleinen LHC gehabt bei sich. Und da hat er einfach Versuche damit machen können. Und hat irgendwie was entdeckt, was irgendwie nachhaltig die Menschheit beeinflussen kann.
Wow, weisst du, und ich bin meine viral-fucking-Videos.
Naja, viel Spaß, macht mal, bringt Leuten mal was bei, guckt mal, schreibt mal ein Buch auf.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Macht's gut.
Ciao, ciao.